The one commodity that is most valuable.
Oh,
and this earth is time,
time to love,
to live.
From the moment the human body is born,
it begins dying.
I don't think you,
man,
you quite caught that.
Let me say it again.
From the moment the human body is born,
it begins dying.
Some happening faster,
some happening slower.
Some of US help them happy,
go faster.
Some of them prevented from happening
sooner than later.
Coach high coming to you live on the
field of life.
How many seconds?
How many minutes do we waste every day?
Doing things that are nowhere near the
goals and aspirations and passions that
we have inside.
How many times are you go through the
course of a day and realize,
did I do anything I set out to do today?
Write down those goals each and every
day.
No matter if there's two goals a day.
If you can accomplish those,
then you're doing more than just making
it through the day you are living and
achieving your dreams.
You know as inspirational speakers,
we don't want to just talk to you.
We want to live that as well.
I've done that in my life as well.
Find time to better yourself.
Read,
explore research,
live life,
do things you've never thought of doing
before.
That's what it's all about when you're
born,
that's their date that they put on the
left side of the tombstone.
When you die,
they put another date on the right side
of the tombstone,
but that dash in the middle is the most
important thing on that tombstone.
That is alone.
That throughout that entire timeframe
you were able to impact and touch others
lives.
You were able to leave your mark on this
earth.
You were able to build a legacy there.
Nobody could change.
You were able to have it to where people
remember who you are,
no matter what.
When you're living for that dash in the
middle,
you're going to remember your why,
your why.
Why are you here,
not,
not the why.
Why did you do something your why,
your reason for getting up in the
morning,
your reason for pushing yourself past
the brink of exertion and given up your
reason for moving on and and and getting
things done in life.
That dash in the middle.
That's the thing that pushes you.
Just stop for a second.
Write down your why.
What are you doing this for in life?
If your does it make you cry and that's
not your why.
Again,
if your why doesn't make you cry,
then that's not your why.
Your why should be something so big that
it moves your family tree.
it changes the whole outlook on how
things are with you and your home,
your family,
your religion,
your purpose.
Think about your passion,
thinking about your opportunities and
that's how you find your purpose.
OPP.
Yeah.
When ned,
why meets up with your passion,
your opportunity,
your purpose,
then you'll find out the most important
day in your life is the day you remember
why you were born,
how you can live an easy life.
You know,
accomplishing goals and be successful
and going out in the world and as tough.
The only way to live an easy life is to
basically give up on all your dreams and
aspirations and just sit around doing
nothing.
Shit that is easy is not worth
accomplishing.
Therefore a life that is easy.
It's not even worth living.
Nothing in this world is worth having,
are doing unless it means effort,
pain,
and difficulty.
Would you listen to me?
He used to be good.
You are going to die.
All of you,
all your friends,
your family,
everyone you know,
everyone you care about,
it's going to die if you love life,
not waste time because time is what life
is made of.
So if you respect and appreciate the
time that you've been given,
one,
you out there doing what you want to do,
where you need to be telling yourself is
it's an acceptable to be seen around the
procrastinate.
And I no longer wanted to be a loser.
I no longer want to be awkward.
I know what it is that I want and I'm
going to work hard and I'm going to get
it.
When you want to succeed,
as bad as you want to breathe,
then you'll be successful.
Someone you lost late morning.
My success,
and I'm here to tell you today,
if you're going to be successful,
you've got to be willing to give up
sleep.
You gotta be willing to work on for
three hours of sleep,
two hours.
If you really want to be successful,
some days you will have to stay up three
days in a row,
but you don't need to
if you don't really want it.
How badly are you wanting success rather
than actually working towards your
dreams?
A lot of you are just thinking about it.
I have high hopes for everybody watching
this.
I want to remember your name.
It is not the things we do in life that
we regret on our deathbed.
It is the things we do,
not because I assure you I've done a lot
of really stupid things.
None of them bothered me.
All the mistakes and all the dopey
things and all the times I was
embarrassed.
They don't matter.
Find your passion and in my experience,
no matter what you do at work,
what you do in official settings,
that passion will be grounded in people.
Pound,
grounded in the relationships you have
with people and what they think of you.
When your time comes
in the teeth of these stupefying odds,
which is you and buy,
you know ordinariness.
That's right here.
Oh,
one thing I can tell you every single
day of my life,
if I trying to find somebody else to
change their life,
I waited till 39 to get married because
I had to wait that long.
Or for happiness was more important,
the Fi,
and if nothing else,
I hope that all of you can find that
kind of passion and that kind of love in
your lungs.
Thank you.
A Journey of a thousand miles begins
with a single step,
so I'm an old Chinese proverb.
Most people have heard it or have come
across it at some point and the meanings
pretty straightforward,
right?
And advocates having the courage to take
that step towards a goal and that's
huge,
and making that decision to move forward
towards something you want,
but it's what happens immediately
following that first step that I'm
interested in.
What happens when the journey's be gone
and it's you and your goal in all of a
sudden you realize how long that road
ahead really is.
Now this is a turning point for a lot of
people and those who can succeed or able
to take their daunting,
intimidating goal or journey and see it
for what it really is.
Just a bunch of small manageable tasks
strung together.
You know,
when you look at why people quit,
a lot of the time it's because they were
overwhelmed by their goals and
ambitions.
Well,
let's say you have this wonderful plan
in your head to climb a mountain.
You're thinking about that feeling of
being on top,
looking down with pride.
Every time you think about it,
your heart starts racing,
so you pack your stuff,
you make your way down in the base of
the mountain and then you look up
different ballgame right now,
the entire mountains in front of you and
you realize that that's no small feat.
That is when people walk away,
when they aren't able to see a challenge
as a sum of tiny steps.
They see it as a crazy impossible task.
It's like saying you want to be the next
Tom Brady or coby bryant to tall
mountain to climb,
like trying to hit a target from a mile
away.
But if you can identify and map out what
you need to conquer in order to become a
better basketball player,
a football player,
and begin taking those small steps
improving every day,
that makes dreams real.
That's what gives goals life,
the ability to see your objective not as
a marathon,
but as a series of little 400 meters
stretches,
stepping stones.
You know what your objective is today,
tomorrow,
the end of the week and the end of the
year,
and then completing them day by day.
These little victories,
that's what gives you a dream life.
It's what gives you momentum.
You feel good about the process
and by the way,
when things blow up in your face,
which happens every so often on this
little place we call earth,
you'll have that foundation and that
sense of accomplishment to stay focused
because your approach is tangible and
it's realistic.
This applies with everything.
Losing a job,
a breakup,
failing a test.
These things that are monumental.
If you allow them to be,
you know,
they can turn into that unclimbable
mountain
or they can roll map a new path for you.
And if you define what you want,
you define success and begin stepping
towards it one hour,
one day at a time,
you'll get where you want to be quicker
than you thought.
What changes our whole life is action.
Why don't we take action?
Fear?
Well,
we got to do to get ourselves to do it.
We got to make sure that we push
ourselves through it by making a
decision.
The point in which change happens is
that decision,
every change in your life that you want
will come from something simple.
A decision people are,
what does it take to change?
Decide
if I persist,
if I continue to try,
if I continue to trudge forward,
I succeed.
I will persist until I succeed.
I was not delivered under this world in
defeat,
nor does failure course in my veins.
I am not a sheep waiting to be prodded
by my shepherd.
I am a lion and I refuse to talk,
to walk,
to sleep with the sheet.
Don't be a follower.
Be a student.
Take advice but not orders.
Take information.
But don't let somebody you know order
your life not to do what someone else
says.
Take what someone else says.
Processing.
Think about it.
Ponder it makes you wonder,
makes you think,
then it's valuable.
Then when you go take action,
make sure that the actions,
not what somebody told you.
Make sure the action is the product of
your own.
What I'm exactly where I wanted to be
because I realized I've got to commit my
very being to this thing.
I gotta I gotta read it.
I got to eat it and until you get there
will never be successful.
Once you get there,
I guarantee you the world is yours.
Stay out of the clutches of mediocrity.
Can Bench yourself.
Reinvent yourself.
Change your tone and shave so often that
they can never categorize you.
Reinvigorate yourself and accept what is
be self taught and reinvent your life
because you mentioned it to you'll life
and they choose to
belongs only to you.
Positive Vibes.
What my hope is to pick tool,
not
everybody that comes in and out.
Your life is put in place.
If this is just a totally happy place,
this
gain the courage and to
every body is put in place in your life,
not to fail.
No,
I never want to be that nine to five
person that just lives my entire life
working a nine to five and just be happy
with a modest lifestyle.
Um,
you know,
being secure.
A lot of people,
that's all they want and they just want
a secure lifestyle.
Um,
you know,
own a house,
and be able to retire and that makes
them happy,
you know?
And I just believe that we should always
be,
always be pushing,
you know,
to achieve more.
It's become more,
you know,
and sit at a job.
The same job for 30 years is not
something I would ever choose to do in
the society.
Know we,
we are tied to go to college and get a
job.
That's what we're taught.
If you become a doctor or a lawyer,
you're successful,
you know.
But most of the time you still have a
boss,
so have someone you know Tony what to do
and you still have this schedule and you
have to stick to,
um,
you know,
so it's not much different than working
at Mcdonald's.
I mean it's just you're making more
money but you're still on the same exact
situation.
And you know,
working at Mcdonald's is not sinking or
same scenario and making more money,
you know,
to me,
you got to enjoy what you're doing and
you know,
to have the lifestyle and the freedom to
do what you want when you want.
You know,
it was the most incredible thing.
People don't understand it.
You got to work hard at whatever you do,
whether you're working for someone else
or working for yourself.
And if you want to put that in,
you know,
you're going to end up being successful.
You can't be satisfied.
But that's what keeps us going.
You know,
when you become content then whites over
the mentality is what's going to make
things happen,
you know,
is having a mentality of never give up,
keep pushing forward and trying to
accomplish your goals.
And hopefully that you have more goals,
constantly trying to move on to bigger
and better things and trying to improve
ourselves in every area.
You really have to believe what you're
doing is working.
You know,
it was very important to believe you
have to believe to achieve.
If you're doing something,
you're not hundred percent confident
what you're doing,
you're going to fail.
You know,
someone who is doing something,
maybe not 100% correctly,
but they truly believe in their mind
that they're doing the best they can
possibly do and they believe what
they're doing is the best possible
scenario.
I think they're going to have a lot more
success than someone that is doing it
100% right but aren't positive and what
they're doing.
You know,
the mind is the most powerful tool we
have.
And in order to be a winner,
you have to lose.
You know,
you know,
that's,
that's how you learn.
You know,
one day I may is telling me I better get
out there and you know,
start busting your ass,
you know,
going forward and never stopped.
Don't miss a day.
You know one day miss is that you can't
get back.
Always.
Always look at the positive.
You know the glass is always half full.
If you think positive and you look at
the positive,
you know you're,
you're only going to continue to get
better.
And it's being positive in every area is
the secret.
You know,
it's a secret to life.
If you're negative about anything you're
going to fail no matter what it is.
You're not happy,
you want to be better.
But that's what you one in every aspect.
Like you want to better yourself and
every way
a lot of people,
you
know,
and it just comes around,
goes around.
The most important thing is fight in
life and not give a shit what other
people think.
You know?
That's the most important thing.
And to have that kind of an attitude or
mentality is rare.
You know,
people are always concerned about what
other people think,
no matter who they are.
It really doesn't matter what other
people think,
you know?
It really doesn't matter if you can have
that kind of mentality is so much
further in life.
People don't like to think they like to
ask.
No,
they don't like to fake.
And they don't have enough confidence in
their decisions that they make on their
own.
When they get advice from someone else,
that gives them more confidence to
believe that that's going to work.
We should always be trying,
you know,
to be better at every aspect in life.
I mean,
you know,
are you a good husband?
Are you a good wife?
Are you a good son?
You know,
are you a good,
you know,
whatever it could be.
You know,
there's a million things in life that we
are,
we,
I think we should constantly be trying
to be better in every area.
I kind of liked to just,
you know,
relax,
enjoy life and that's kind of what I do.
Um,
and being able to,
to not stress and do what I want to do
when I want to do it.
It's just a great feeling.
Whatever it takes to get you to try
harder.
Read Mar,
set your goals and go for it.
Here's the next attitude.
Disease over caution.
Okay.
Some people never will have much there
too cautious.
Now you can also be too reckless,
but you can also be too cost.
Yes.
This is called the timid approach to
life
and my caution was always the risk.
Risk used to drive me right up the wall.
I used to say,
what if this happened?
It's called the language of the poor.
What if this happens?
And on top of that,
if this was to happen,
look at the Phipps ib and I better not
try.
Okay?
I could always ask myself out.
Then I'll tell you what changed my whole
life when I finally discovered it's all
risky.
Yeah.
The minute you were born at got risky.
If you think trying is risky,
wait til they hand you the bill for not
trying.
If you think investing is risky,
wait till you get the tab or not
investing.
See,
it's all risky.
Getting married is risky.
Having children as risky,
going into business is risky.
Investing your money as risky.
It's all risky.
I'll tell you how risky life is.
You're not going to get out alive.
Huh?
That's risky.
They Englishman says,
well,
if that's the way it's going to work
out,
let's give it a go.
Right?
That's what it's for.
Give it a go.
Somebody says,
yeah,
but I'm looking for safety and security.
Find then huddle in a corner,
little cover you with a sheet.
Bring it three meals a day and we'll
protect you.
Feed you.
Look after you care for you.
We won't let anything happen to you and
you'll probably live to be 100
the guy said,
well,
yeah,
I'd live to be 100 but what a way to
live,
right?
What a way to live safe and secure dog.
Ask for security.
Ask for adventure.
Better to live 30 years full of
adventure than a hundred years safe in
the corner
and see it's not important how long you
live.
What's important is how you live.
Here's the next attitude.
Disease.
We're almost through with this motley
list.
In fact,
we're almost through.
Hang on.
The next one is pessimism.
Okay?
Pessimism,
the deadly disease of always looking on
the bad side,
the problem side,
the difficult side,
checking all the reasons why it can't be
done.
The poor pessimists leads an ugly life.
He doesn't try to figure out what's
right.
He tries to figure out what's wrong.
He doesn't look for virtue.
He looks for faults and when he finds
him,
he's delighted how ugly
this is.
The poor guy looks through the window,
doesn't see the sunset.
He sees the specs on the window
and this is the poor guy,
right?
Who rushes up,
takes us to leave of your senses.
This guy rushes up and he says,
I've got five good reasons why it won't
work.
He's so dumb.
He doesn't know.
All you need is one.
He's got five
to the pessimists.
The glass is always half m d to the
optimist.
The glass is half full.
Why would the same measure affect
people?
Two different ways.
Answer.
It all depends on how you look at it.
Our lives are mostly affected by the way
we think.
Things are not the way they are.
The way we think they are affects us
know.
Yeah.
There's a subject we don't have time to
get into tonight called better thinking
habits.
One of the major things shoaff taught me
when I met him.
He said,
poor thinking habits keeps most people
poor,
not poor working habits.
Most people work hard,
but they don't think hard.
And shoaff taught me that the mind is
like a factory,
a mental factory,
and whatever you think about all day
long pours ingredients into this mental
factory,
and that's what bill's,
the economic,
social,
financial fabric of your life.
He quoted me a Bible phrase that says as
you think so you become
how awesome.
When he talked about poor thinking
habits,
he had me,
I used to start the day reading the
morning newspaper.
I mean,
you can leave that or not.
I'd get a cup of coffee and read the
paper.
I load up on wars and riots and murders
and stabbings and killings and bank
robberies or muggings and car wrecks and
tragedies.
I'd even read the back pages.
I seem to like that stuff for some weird
reason.
I'd load up on all that and then I start
the day.
You can imagine the kind of days I used
to have you walk around on your
financial needs.
They call you economic peewee.
Good.
The guy says,
I want to be a great leader.
Wonderful.
The first thing we do is follow him to
his house.
When we get there,
we walk in and check his library.
Number one,
somebody says,
well,
why check his library?
The reason is because what a man reads
pours massive ingredients in to his
mental factory and the fabric of his
life is built from those ingredients.
You would not believe what some people
have got in their house to read.
You would not believe one of the best
dressed up boards.
I know for a lot of it is trash.
Can you imagine dumping a bale of trash
into this mental factory every day and
coming out with a rich dynamic,
positive life?
It can be done.
You might as well try making a cake with
cement.
The kids back in Danbury,
Connecticut High School,
they're asking me questions.
One day I'm talking to the kids.
Kids got good questions these days.
One of them said to me,
Mr Rohan,
how do you build the good life?
I said,
it's simple.
It's not easy,
but it's simple.
Here's how you build anything.
Select the right ingredients,
keep out the wrong ingredients,
and it starts with thought.
Everything starts with thought,
so you must be wise and careful what you
think about because that starts
everything.
Okay?
You gotta be wise and careful.
I asked the kids
what would happen if somebody drops
sugar in my coffee?
They said,
well,
you'd be okay.
I said,
what if somebody dropped strychnine in
my coffee?
They said,
well,
you'd be dead.
I said,
correct.
Less than one life is both sugar and
strict nine
you got a big care full.
I said,
what is my worst enemy?
Drops in the sugar.
They said,
well,
you'll be okay.
I said,
what if my best friend,
even by accident drops in the
strychnine?
They said,
well,
you'd be dead.
I said,
correct lesson to watch your cough.
You gotta be careful.
See,
it doesn't matter who hands you the bad
stuff.
It doesn't matter where you get the bad
It'll still do its damage on your bank
account wherever you get it.
Mr Shelf gave me one of the greatest
phrases when I first met him when he
said,
gym every day.
Stand guard at the door of your mind.
How important.
Stand guard at the door of your mind
and you decide what goes into your
mental factory.
Don't let anybody just dump anything
they want to in your mental factory
cause you've got to live with the
results.
Okay,
here's the last disease and we're
through with this list.
In fact,
we're almost through.
Hang on.
The last subject is very brief,
the last disease,
but this one is deadly.
Engage in this.
When indulgent it even slightly and you
might as well forget the future because
it's going to forget you complaining,
crying,
whining,
griping,
a Bible word called murmuring.
See,
that'll ace your future.
Spend five minutes complaining and you
have wasted five and you may have begun
what's known as economic cancer of the
bone.
Surely they will soon haul you off into
a financial desert and there let you
choke on the dust of your own regret.
I hope I said that well so you won't
forget.
It's a deadly disease.
If you don't think it's bad,
ask the children of Israel of Old
Testament fame.
Typical of us all their story just
happened to get in the book.
Story says,
children of Israel were slaves.
God performed a series of dazzling
miracles and got him out,
and now they're heading for the promised
land.
Remember,
the story hadn't for the promise land
tragedy of the story.
They never got their reason from day
one.
They started to complain.
They griped about the water.
They griped about the weather.
They whined and cried and griped about
the food they griped about the
leadership.
They whined and cried because it was too
far,
too cold,
too hot,
too difficult,
too miserable.
I mean,
they widened,
whined and cried for years.
Finally,
God said,
I've added tip canceled
or something like that.
The story says they died in the desert,
never got to the promised land.
Okay?
Which I think means two things.
Indulge in this long enough.
You get your future cancer,
and I guess it also means even God
himself can only take so much,
okay?
Just be on the lookout of the things
that can destroy all the good you start
the war is on.
Yeah,
and this evening.
Tomorrow,
mentally,
personally,
socially,
economically.
You got to make sure you're winning the
war.